eric sean fox news ambassador when will
vladimir putin stop his war crimes when
will you stop this obscene
assault against ukraine and will
vladimir putin surrender
and what
will vladimir putin
and what's surrender what
surrender your assault and barbaric war
against ukraine will you stop in the
sake of humanity when when the
goals of the of the special military
operations are achieved it will stop it
was
it was announced from the very beginning
uh
i must tell you that i i appreciate your
humane approach but i didn't see that
humane approach
in all these eight years when ukrainian
forces uh ukrainian armed forces and
radicals were shelling and bombing uh
donetsk and lugansk without any reproach
basically any reproach from the
international community from the
no comments from the
un officials on that on the tissue
yesterday yesterday there was a barbaric
attack
of the ukrainian armed forces who used
cluster munitions in which russia is
is
accused
from
based on on sources which which cannot
cannot be identified but they use the
cluster munition in center of donetsk 21
persons that person
died
30 plus wounded
no comments i was looking through news
including west media today i didn't come
across a single article
uh on that on that barbaric attack
yesterday secretary general made
made a stakeout
he didn't say a word on that attack
only one asked the question he said that
if that was deliberate it is condemnable
uh i must tell you that we are very much
concerned how unofficial including the
top ones uh including the secretary
junior general including under secretary
general eros marie de carlo are
assessing the situation the situation in
in ukraine uh
accusing russia over in discriminant
attacks secretary general yesterday said
that
although that attack is condemnable uh
the most of the of the uh
destruction comes from the russian
sources as if he was he was comparing
two events and and
uh implying that
implying that
that attack didn't deserve condemnation
pamela falk from cbs news as you know
my question is about a ceasefire what
would it take
for
russia to have an overall not just
humanitarian ceasefire what does ukraine
need to do and what's in your resolution
what what are you proposing on
humanitarian carters thank you i decided
i cited a few
things obvious for a humanitarian
resolution you will see it soon shortly
because it will be it will be published
for an overall season negotiated
ceasefire negotiated ceasefire of course
it should be negotiated and this
ceasefire will
will take place when
when
conditions that were put forward
by russia will be implemented and
they're very well known and can you just
lay out what those conditions are
uh demilitarization of ukraine
denuncification of ukraine
no threat which would come from the
territory from that country
to russia
no
no
joining nato president zilensky
announced
just a few hours perhaps ago that
he understands that
that the ukraine will not join not
citing
in particular his disappointment with
the way that nato reacted but uh that
but the goal of ukraine joining nato is
in the ukrainian constitution so it
should be it should be dropped from
there uh first and foremost i think that
i think that's enough question
ambassador are the
parallels here sir between the u.s
invasion of iraq in 2003 you've been
very critical russia has been very
critical you've also been very critical
of the 2011 invasion attack on libya led
by nato
are there parallels between what the us
did in 2003 and the unilateral actions
we are seeing from from russia and the
criticism that is being leveled against
u.n officials that are simply seeking to
defend the u.n charter
every situation is unique but i do not
recall the level of
outrage hysterics that
that
that
that u.s
invasion of iraq uh
no resolutions nothing if you remember
no resolution of the security council uh
nothing that would be comparable to what
what we're experiencing today thank you
very much